all right good afternoon everybody I am
je parle
gonna be talking to you about finding
bugs without running or even looking at
your code now this talk is from the
general class of things called formal
methods there is a slack channel formal
methods if you want to join talk to talk
to other like-minded folks so this is a
pretty big claim I'm making here and
you'd be fairly reasonable to say
impossible right how can we possibly
find budge without looking at the code
or even running the code well how are a
few ways that we find bugs right now is
it there's at least a couple we can all
probably think of off the top of our
heads reviewing PRS right awesome way to
find bugs in fact it's one of the best
ways to find bugs testing manual and
automated testing you're definitely
gonna find bugs like that static
analyzers really cool tools that can
analyze your codebase find bugs that
humans often can't find the problem with
all these and other methods though is
that they all require that either you or
a tool is looking at your code or that
your code is running in the case of
testing and I'm not interested any of
that for today so what then is my secret
solution to finding bugs without running
or looking at code is this talking to an
expert and writing stuff down you just
start there and you're gonna be in a
great place now
who could this expert be this could be
the architects or the developers the
technical documentation writers anyone
that has a really solid understanding of
the system being described but how do
you actually find code or find bugs by
talking to someone well I want you to
think back to situations you might have
been in the past I certainly have where
you are explaining a system or an
algorithm or a problem you've got to
someone else or maybe they're explaining
something like that to you and in the
process of describing this algorithm
system or problem the explainer stops
like that wonderful look on their face
and they go aha I figured it out I just
realized my problem or I just realized a
bug I never thought of before all right
there's something about the process
of explaining things to people that
seems to cause our brain to work in a
different way and explore paths of
execution for your system that you might
not otherwise have considered now this
could be because the listener asks a
very astute question at the right time
but definitely that definitely happens
but for me I've had a lot of instances
where the listener doesn't say a word
and I still have that aha moment and in
fact you don't even have to have a
listener the simple process of writing
down on paper what you know about a
system or what you think you know about
a system will often clarify your
thinking in a way you might not
otherwise have done and cause bugs to be
exposed now this is a favorite quote of
mine writing is nature's way of letting
you know how sloppy your thinking is
it's a popular quote informal method
circles and the reason for this is what
I was just saying that simple process of
putting pen to paper and describing your
system clarifies our thinking and in an
often unexpected way leads us to think
about our systems in a different way
than normal so looking at the clock here
were three minutes into the talk and
there's a couple things you're probably
thinking to yourselves at this point one
might be how should we write down our
thoughts or designs or plans or
strategies around a system great
question another question you might be
asking did I really come to a talk about
bug discovery where the solution is go
talk to people and write stuff down both
very valid questions I'll tackle that
first one first so there's lots of ways
you can write things down in formal
natural language descriptions UML
diagram pseudocode state machine
descriptions sequence diagrams whatever
you want
just it's important that you're taking a
different approach to your system you're
writing it down in something that is not
code you're letting your brain think at
a more abstract level than the code now
a way I like
to write stuff down is to use something
a little bit more formal than natural
language descriptions I like to describe
my systems in a way that not only does
it help my thinking but a computer can
understand my thinking and in doing this
I can leverage the massive brute force
power of modern computers to not only
help me have more of those aha moments
but so sometimes the computer can have
those aha moments all on its own and
fortunately for everybody in the
audience I think the way I like to do
that also answers the second question
I'm not just gonna stand here and say
talk to people and write stuff down that
is an excellent strategy and if you only
take one thing away from the talk today
let it be that write more things down it
will clarify your thinking and it'll
cause you to find bugs but that's not
going to be the focus today today I'm
gonna talk about this it's a tool called
alloy from MIT
unfortunately the font size is on the
buttons are not configurable so I'll
just have to tell you what what they
mean later on alloy comes from the
general class of tools called model
checkers and if you're not familiar with
a model checker what they are is they're
a system that lets you describe your
code describe your design in a formal
way such that your computer leveraging
that massive brute force power we now
all have in our laptops your computer
can use that formal design to explore
the entire sequence are every single
sequence of operations your program
might ever enter every single state your
program might ever enter and while doing
that it can check that search and
correctness properties are always
holding and if it if the model checker
finds any state in which a correctness
property fails it'll tell you right away
and it'll say hey you've got a bug there
alright so in other words we're using I
shouldn't in other words we're using
model checkers to help our thought
process alright we're leveraging this
massive brute force power of computers
to explore
so before I actually open the real tool
that's just a screenshot let me describe
the example I'm going to build up in the
tool so this is a very simple example of
a permission system it's gonna have
three kinds of things in it it counts
resources and users and that's it
resources and users are gonna belong to
accounts users potentially have the
ability to access a resource think of
that like the user has permission on the
resource so the user has a role into the
resource resources can optionally have a
parent resource and why would we want to
do that well the reason is that in this
permission system we want to say if a
user has access to a parent resource
then they implicitly get access to all
of the that parents children okay so
that's the example we're gonna build up
I bet a lot of you could take these five
points here go write some code and build
a great system around this but I'm not
that smart so I need I need to write
things down so let's take a look at
alloy and see what this looks like okay
so what we have here is that same alloy
tool I've fed in a little bit of the
design so we you can see right now we
have three things we have accounts users
and resources you can think of the word
cig kind of like class or type def
something along those lines so right now
we're telling alloy this system we'd
want a design is gonna have accounts
users and resources in it great what can
we do with this at this point well
there's a lightning bolt icon here that
says execute which may or may not be
readable on the projector I'm gonna
click that and instantly within a
millisecond alloy says instance found
now what does that mean instance found
what click didn't take a look so what we
have here is a valid instance of this
system based on the description I've
given alloy thus far Allah has said okay
we can have users and resources and
accounts here's a valid instance of your
system in which two accounts have been
instantiated great not super interesting
but it's always neat to see diagrams
coming out of a program
now there's another button here and the
visualizer called next and I'm gonna
click that and what alwah is going to do
is generate a completely different valid
instance of this system so this instance
has two accounts and one user no
resource is still but this is just the
instance owl I decided to generate this
time I'll click next once more here we
go two accounts one resource one user so
we can look at this and as programmers
we can say well the system we talked
about had resources and users belonging
to accounts nothing in this diagram
shows anything belonging to anything
there's no hierarchy here there's no
structure here that's because we haven't
told alloy about any structure so let's
go back in and add a little bit of
structure to our design I'm not brave
enough to type things out live so I've
got different files here we're just
pretend I instantly typed it out
perfectly every time
so now you can see I've added some
attributes to these classes or to these
cigs and think of it like
object-oriented program we're adding
attributes to an object type so the
account cig or the account class now has
a resources attribute and that resources
attribute is going to point to zero or
more resources in other words these are
the resources that belong to the account
the account sig also has a users
attribute which points to zero or more
users in other words these are the users
that are going to belong to a given
account the user object or type itself
also has the resources attribute but
here this is going to represent the set
of zero or more resources that the user
has permission to access and finally on
the resource we have a parent attribute
and remember we said a resource can
optionally have a parent so that means
it can have zero parents or one parent
and that's what the loan keyword does it
means less than or equal to one so every
resource is going to have less than or
equal to one parent resource okay so
that's you know maybe a little bit
interesting let's click execute start
generating fresh instances fresh
possible scenarios the system could
enter enter and take a look so this
diagram looks a
more interesting than we just saw right
there's actual structure here in this
particular instance alloy generated it
has said okay given the description
you've given me here's an instance with
two accounts one resource and or two
resources and one user we can see that
resource one belongs to account zero
resource 0 belongs to account 1 and our
user belongs to both accounts now I
don't know if you've ever done anything
in the realm of security but you
probably don't want a user belonging to
two separate customer accounts sometimes
you do in this case we don't
so what alloy has done here just by
showing us a possible instance of our
system it's illustrated a problem to us
I just had an aha moment I realized that
my design is not precise enough I
haven't actually specified in my formal
design that every user can only belong
to one account so how are we going to do
that type type type really fast I added
this thing here called a fact a fact is
a constraint that we place on the system
al aliy will only generate instances now
that satisfy this constraint and what
does this fact say it says that for
every user you there's going to be
exactly one account a for which you
belongs to account a alright in other
words a user can only belong to one
account now when I click execute
al is going to generate fresh instances
again and you can see in this particular
instance we now have the user just
belonging to one account I could click
Next probably 10,000 times every one of
those 10,000 times it's going to show me
a different scenario and in every single
one of those scenarios each user will
only belong to one account so great
we're doing better but I see more
problems here I'm having more of these
aha moments in this particular instance
resource 0 belongs to account 1 that's
fine resource one belongs to account 0
that's also fine but there's a
parent-child relationship between those
two resources from a security
perspective you probably don't want that
as well if
customer zero owns this thing and
customer one owns this thing you
probably don't want a link between those
two things so again we haven't been
precise enough in our specification we
thought we we didn't think about
possible scenarios so let's fix that
type type type I've added another fact
here all the facts must be true all the
time so our previous fact is still there
but I've added another fact that says
for each resource are if the resource
has a parents because remember we said
it's optional for a resource to have a
parent but if a resource has a parent it
implies there's going to be exactly one
account for which R belongs to that
account and which for ours parent
belongs to that account in other words
if a resource has a parent they're both
going to belong to the same account so
let's execute see if our if we're now
happy with the diagrams we're getting so
that's a little better the resources are
in the same account but again I'm seeing
another problem maybe maybe you see it
here resource 1 has itself as a parent
that seems weird I probably don't want
to allow that in my system I don't even
know what that would mean again maybe
some systems that's what you want before
the system we're designing I don't want
that so let's fix that we're gonna add
another fact and other constraints and
this fact says that there shall be no
resource R for which R is its own
parents or R is not in its own chain of
parents don't worry too much if you
don't understand that I can talk to you
about it later well click execute take a
look at the instances alright so here's
a fresh instance not too interesting but
I don't see any problems here another
one no one is it so impaired antenna
more that's pretty good
users we're all doing the right things
this looks pretty good you know and I
could go through for a while here I
don't I normally wouldn't but I couldn't
go through for a while and just stop
when I'm happy but I'm not happy because
I just came to a diagram or something
else weird is happening this user that
belongs to account one
has permissions on resources from
account zero we probably don't want that
either
you don't want customer you don't want
users from one customer account getting
roles on something from another customer
account so alloy I again has given me
one of these aha moments something I
didn't think about that we need to fix
so that's what this fact here does this
is saying for every possible combination
of user and accounts if the user is in
that account it implies that all of the
users resources or all the resources the
user has permission to are also in that
account and now when I execute generate
instances I can click Next forever and
we're not going to see any of those
problems so let's go back to the alloy
for a moment here what we've been doing
thus far is having a lloyd generate
instances and we've been pretty lucky in
that right away we found problems almost
every time that's that's great and
oftentimes you will find problems almost
right away what if there's something in
particular we want to check for we want
to see if something is possible I don't
want to click next 10,000 times that's
ridiculous so what alloy has is the
concept of invariance or assertions if
you like and I'm gonna add an assertion
in here and an assertion you use with
the check keyword and an assertion is a
belief you have about the system that we
want our way to check for us so it is my
belief that for every single resource
there's always going to be exactly one
accounts that the resource belongs to
now this is kind of a made-up example
because I know it's not the case and I
think if you've been thinking through
this you might realize we haven't
actually said that a resource can only
belong to one account so obviously owl
is gonna find a problem here so I'm
gonna ask Ali to check this for me and
if there is a problem in which my belief
is not true it'll show it to me so I'm
expecting to see a diagram in which your
resource belongs to two different
accounts right I think that makes a lot
of sense so this time I have to use the
drop-down menu here but I'll click check
and it says counterexample found so Ali
found a scenario in which my belief is
incorrect so we're probably going to
click this and we're going to see a
resource belonging to two accounts we
though and I honestly never thought of
this the first time I put these this
presentation together here's a resource
that belongs to no accounts the belief
we had was that the way we wrote it is
that every resource is going to belong
to exactly one account our implicit
notion there was well because we don't
want a resource belonging to two
accounts but what alloys said was well
here's a case where a resource doesn't
belong to one account it doesn't belong
to any accounts and we probably don't
want that either so let's put a little
fix in for that we're going to add a new
fact don't worry too much about the
syntax of this one but it's saying that
it's basically forcing every resource to
belong to an account so now let's let's
check this counter or check this
property again we're going to get a
counter example more like what we
expected here's one in which there's a
resource that belongs to two separate
accounts all right which is what we
thought we would see so now we can fix
that particular scenario I'm gonna add a
little bit more to the fact here and
this is saying there shall be no two
accounts such that those accounts share
any resources that's another way of
saying a resource can't belong to two
accounts simultaneously now when I check
we're good it says no counter example
found now one last thing I want to do in
alloy is I said that if a user has
access to a parent resource they should
implicitly get access to all of the
parents children okay and now we can
start to model some of the logic we
might use in our actual code when we go
to implement this in Python or Java or
go or whatever you like and so we're
gonna have this predicate which is a
function that returns true or false and
this is the logic I decide to use to
model whether or not a user can access a
resource so this function is going to
take a u and an R which are a user and a
resource and able to return true if the
resource is in the set of resources the
user has permission on or it'll return
true if the resource has a parent and
that parent is in the set of resources
the user has permission on ok so this is
the lie
we would potentially use in our software
to actually check whether someone should
be allowed to access a given resource
and now just because I wrote this logic
down doesn't mean I've actually done
everything correctly so we want to have
another check we wanted to Clara nother
property that we believe to be true but
we want alloy to check for us and this
is saying that I believe that for every
possible combination of user and
resource if the user can access the
resource then it implies that the user
can access all of the children of the
resource okay and if you're not
following nine percent I know this is
new to probably 99% of you don't worry
I'm just trying to give you a taste of
it so let's do this check here see what
Ally says about our belief instantly
Ally says counterexample found I have
found a situation in which your belief
is not true which it's legitimately
surprising because like I thought that
this can access was okay so let's look
at the counter example now because of
the resolution I have to scroll a little
bit but what it's saying here is that
resource 0 is in the set of resources
that user 1 has direct permission on ok
and resource 0 is the parents of
resource 1 and user 1 gets permission to
access a resource 1 through that
parent-child relationship but but here's
the problem
user 1 has access to resource 1 through
that parent-child relationship but they
don't have access to resource 2 and
that's what I intended if there's any
parent-child relationship it should go
all the way down from the top parent to
the bottom child in that chain and given
what we've declared here the user would
not actually have access to this
resource ok so I'm not going to fix this
today but I just want to give you a
taste of what it's like to check these
properties in a lowly and sometimes the
surprising well oftentimes the
surprising results that you're going to
have so what did we actually do in this
nice little alo example well we did what
I call two things we did a design
validation at the end the validation is
where I was declaring properties I
believed to be true and Ally was
checking
or not those properties actually were
true and this is an incredibly powerful
aspect of model checkers and it is one
of the biggest reasons people use them
and it's an amazing reason to use them
the model checker has an ability to
check properties that we just can't
write unit tests for it's too hard to
come up with all the possible
permutations of unit tests model
checkers are incredible at this but
think back to the beginning of that
alloy example what was I doing there we
didn't have any checks until the end I
was just generating diagrams and what
was that process that process was
designed exploration okay it's one thing
to write a property that you believe to
be true when you're deep into the system
and you know what you believe to be true
but what about when you're just starting
out on a new system or you're trying to
understand a system that's been
presented to you you don't even know
what you don't know right so what alloy
does is it gives us a way to explore
possible scenarios that your systems
might enter and then you can look at
those scenarios and decide whether they
make sense or not and whether you have
to do something about it so that was a
pretty trivial example I'm now going to
talk about real-life uses I've had of
alloy and the first one I was at a
previous company and I was helping model
the interaction between multiple systems
in alloy why would we want to do that we
wanted to do it for experimentation
purposes they were proposing adding a
new feature to a very core system we
wanted to see how other systems might be
able to leverage that core feature and
it's a lot easier to experiment with 300
lines of alloy than it is with hundreds
of thousands of lines of Java and Python
across multiple code bases deploy to AWS
or wherever and you know complicated
development environments I'll take the
alloy any day for experimentation
so what systems did I model in the alloy
model
well I modeled multiple customer portals
this this company had a few different
customer facing product portals I
modeled the notion of browser sessions
of an identity provider the notion of
auth tokens and for this particular
company they actually had an old-style
token and a new-style token and
depending which portal you were in it
changed the kind of token you needed I
modeled the notion of sam'l requests and
responses if you're not familiar with
sam'l it's the way that a lot of
companies
do logins for their websites and more
and I didn't just model those systems
from a static view I actually modeled
operations that could take place between
the systems so the operation of a user
choosing to navigate between portals the
operation of portals initiating sam'l
flows they're going to take some time
the notion of identity provider
responding to the sam'l flows the notion
of the identity provider redirecting to
a credentials page for users that
haven't logged in yet the notion of a
user entering either good credentials or
bad credentials or wrong credentials and
you'll see soon what I mean by wrong and
more so I modeled a lot of stuff now one
of the things I did while modeling these
systems is I wrote this property here
and we don't just write properties so
alloy can check them for us we also
write them so other readers of the spec
can get a sense of what we believe to be
true this is really useful documentation
what does this particular property say
it says that there shall be no point in
time T in which 1 of our customer
portals has an auth token for a user
but that same off token is unknown to
our identity provider if that actually
happens it's a security flaw because if
an auth token gets out there to a
customer portal and then the identity
provider loses track of that off token
it means the identity provider can no
longer revoke that token and there's an
enumerable innumerable number of ways in
which you have security flaws if you
can't revoke someone's token all right
both good reasons and bad reasons so I
wrote this property not expecting to
find any problems but then I clicked
execute an alloy counter example found
assertion is invalid what happened I was
very surprised by this
so what alloy did was it generated a
sequence of 13 operations that if they
happen in this particular order would
cause the security flaw now I'm not
going to show you the way alloy drew
that it's a little bit easier I put
together my own little animation to help
describe the sequence of operations that
alloy discovered I did not tell alloy to
run these 13 steps I always figure it
out on its own so here's what out the
scenario alloy discovered that leads to
a security flaw user visits the new
portal so
customer again had a new product portal
in an old portal user visits the new
portal the portal says I don't know who
you are I don't have a session for you
you need a login the portal generates a
sam'l request portal then redirects the
users browser over to the identity
provider identity providers is great I
love sam'l requests but I don't have a
token for this user yet I need to send
the user off to the credentials page
browser gets redirected to the
credentials page at this point though we
have our first mistake the user instead
of entering credentials for the new
portal they enter credentials for the
old portal because this user happens to
have multiple accounts with the company
ok with different sets of credentials
for the different accounts so they enter
old portal credentials old portal creds
one the login page sends those off to
the identity provider the identity
provider says great credentials I'm
going to generate a token from those but
because they're old credentials or old
portal credentials an old-style token is
generated the identity provider then has
to throw away the sam'l request because
it can't send an old token to the new
portal so it holds on to the token
throws away the sam'l request
immediately redirects the users browser
to the old portal user lands at the old
portal the old portal immediately says I
don't have a session for you off to the
identity provider you go with the sam'l
request in tow the identity provider
says great I've got a sam'l request
I love sam'l requests this one is from
the old portal even better I have an old
style token for the old portal so I'm
going to generate a sam'l response send
that back to the old portal the old
portals is great I love sam'l responses
consumes the token in the response holds
on to it now has a session for the user
and the user is confused because the
user meant to login to the new portal
like two minutes ago when I started this
and there's just been like automatic
browser redirects the whole time users
like well something went wrong I meant
to go to the new portal so I'm just
gonna click my bookmark for the new
portal go back there new portal sees the
browser browser says I don't know who
you are I'm gonna generate a sam'l
request sends the user over to the
identity provider identity provider says
great I love salmon requests this is a
salmon request from the new portal I
don't
a new token gotta send you to the
credentials page user goes down to their
credentials page the user makes another
mistake they don't enter those old
portal creds that they enjoyed last time
they don't enter their new portal creds
they enter a different set of old portal
credentials because they have two
different accounts the login page sends
the user back to the identity provider
and here is where the bug was that Ally
found what the identity provider was
doing was saying great credentials I'm
going to generate a token but note what
happens here because it's a different
set of credentials a different token
gets generated now we have old portal
token - in the identity provider we now
have a live token out at a customer
portal that our identity provider
doesn't know about that is what we call
a security flaw we can't revoke that
token anymore okay so this was scary to
me when I saw because I must have done
something wrong and I thought I did
something wrong because I never looked
at a single line of anybody's code to
generate the model for that all right I
had a three hundred line alloy model
that was encompassing the actions of you
know five or six different code bases I
knew roughly what those code bases did
and I had talked to their developers a
little bit but I never looked at any of
their code so I assumed I had made a
mistake in the model but then when I
presented the results the developers
they said yeah we have to delay our
release on Friday because we need to go
fix this problem and I also want to
stress again that I didn't tell alloy
here's a ridiculous sequence of 13 steps
what happens I always figured it out on
its own it figured out that if this
these particular 13 steps were to happen
we would get a flaw so that was one fun
experience I had in previous company
with alloy here's another one so the the
company this time had been working on a
brand new API for a year it put a ton of
effort into it and very shortly five or
six different systems around the company
we're gonna start consuming this API and
I was brought in to help have the first
system integrate with the API great no
problem there the issue was the API was
actually kind of hard
understand through no fault of the API
itself but it was modeling a lot of
pretty intense it had a lot of pretty
intense business logic behind the scenes
and you couldn't really understand how
to use the API unless you understood the
business logic so what did I do to help
myself understand the business logic I
decided to write an alloy model not to
prove anything wrong or prove anything
right but remember what I said before
writing things down helps you think
better alloy helps me think better and
what did this process look like so
that's me on the left I'm Jay again the
developer I spent most of the time
talking to his name's Bob great guy so I
took the documentation for the API and I
built an initial alloy model and while
trying to build that model I realized
there was gaps in the documentation
because I had to write the alloy piece
and there was no corresponding
documentation to tell me what to do so
I'd go to Bob and I'd say hey how does
ABC work what do I do here and he would
always give me an incredibly detailed
very well thought-out answer awesome so
that would give me more information to
build out my model so I'd go iterate
iterate iterate work on it for a little
bit then I would start to generate some
instances once I had the model at a
reasonable enough spot and actually I
had the model at a reasonable enough
spots to generate instances on the first
day but what I'd started to do is I'd
see these kinds of scenarios like we
were looking at before things that
looked off to me like I thought maybe
that shouldn't be possible and I'd say
to Bob hey is this loud like this
diagram here could your system actually
do that and sometimes he'd say nope nope
you've made a mistake in your model and
sometimes he'd say yeah we actually can
do that you've got your model right and
so based on these answers I could refine
the model refine the model iterate
iterate iterate I then added the notion
of operations these sequences of over
time to the model and I'd say hey Bob
could this particular sequence of
operations ever take place and
oftentimes especially at that point he
would say I don't know I have to go look
at the code because like that's a
complex sequence and it would be bad if
that happens so I really hope we have
code to account for that and every
single time he came back and said you've
done the model correct and we're
actually okay or your model has a
we have code that's going to prevent
that bad situation from ever happening
all right so he'd respond back and now
like two weeks worth of minimal
interactions I was doing a lot of other
stuff but just sort of doing this on the
side of Bob working on building this
model and after about the two weeks I I
realized something I realized that the
API that they spent a year on won't work
the API itself was technically brilliant
and did exactly what it was originally
intended to do the problem was the user
experienced folks that had designed the
customer experience had a completely
incorrect understanding of what the API
was capable of and the API itself was
originally designed for something
different and no one was able to
understand the customer experience side
and the API side I came in already
understanding the customer experience
side alloy gave me the tools to build a
mental model of the API side and I
realized oh we can't actually do this
this is a problem so they had to throw
away a year's worth of work which is
never great but it's better to throw
away a year's worth of work than have
six teams do an additional six months of
work trying to integrate with an API
that we're never going to be able to use
so those are two of sort of many
personal examples I have with alloy I've
got just enough time to show this
because I love this this is a this is a
paper or a result from a paper by Pamela
save and what Pamela's Eve had decided
to do was analyze the cord protocol and
if you're not familiar with the cord
protocol it's a distributed hash table
it won the 2011 sigcomm test of time
award for what a great algorithm it was
and the original paper presenting the
core protocol is one of the most cited
papers in all of computer science pretty
good paper within the paper the authors
had seven difference correctness claims
about the protocol our protocol will
always do this our protocol will always
do this and they had mathematical proofs
for all seven claims so what did Pamela
save decided to do well she decided to
model with alloy as I said and she
turned each of those seven claims in
checks the invariance the properties we
looked at before and what do you think
happened with each and every one of
those seven claims Allah found a
counterexample so for every single one
of those claims the authors had made
about this in this incredibly
influential paper every one of those
claims was actually wrong again
Pamela's a on her own didn't initially
figure that out alloy showed her that
these were wrong she was then able to
use owl to fix the protocol and show her
the correctness claims were then correct
but it's it's just a story I love
because there was a great thing that
everybody adored and Ally said no no no
no no no ok so what are the takeaways as
I'm wrapping up here what are the
takeaways I want you all to leave with
first write things down if you never
think about alwa again when you leave
this room that's fine but spend more
time writing things down whether you're
starting a project whether you're trying
to understand a project whether you're
trying to understand an algorithm write
it down and it's something other than
code give your brain a chance to think
about the problem in a different way
hopefully in a more abstract way because
code is not abstract at all I don't care
how many abstraction layers you have
code is not abstract abstract code is so
detailed the next part I want to talk
about or the next takeaway is model
existing systems if you spend enough
time in formal methods land in a model
checker land people like to make a lot
of claims about the power of using tools
like alloy for Greenfield applications
use alloy to create the blueprints for
your at for your system and then use
those blueprints to easily write the
code after that can happen it's cool
when it happens but realistically how
often are we working on greenfield
projects I'd say that as an industry
most of our time is spent maintaining
existing projects or adding features to
existing projects or jumping into
existing projects you don't previously
have experience with modeling those
projects those systems has enormous
benefit not just for finding bugs like
Alli did but for you and your ability
to learn the system in a different way
it's helped me immeasurably over the
years and then finally do that thing I
was just talking about model new systems
if you're working on something green try
using a modeling language oftentimes
you're going to be able to find really
deep subtle problems at the modeling
stage when all you've done is a couple
hundred lines of alloy code and it's
better to find it at that stage than
when you're about to go to production
and you realize a bug that requires you
to change everything right you
definitely don't want that so a few
resources I'll leave you with so we can
get these on the slide for people to
check out later so alloy tools org and
specifically slash book that HTML for
better or for worse the alloy book is
amazing it's written by Daniel Jackson
the author of alloy it is the way almost
everybody learns alloy there's very few
other resources because the book is so
good no one else bothered to spend time
doing anything else i the architecture
of open source applications book is free
online there is an alloy chapter in it
which is just lovely a fantastic
fantastic app you're showing how they
model browser sessions and cores and
security flaws around all of that stuff
I'm going to call out my friend hello
Wayne some of you may know him he helped
me put together the accounts users
resources example I had he was a big
part of the inspiration for that not
only is he an expert on alloy and loves
alloy he is also an expert on tli Plus
and loves ti+ and if this stuff seems
interesting to you he does a really
fantastic corporate workshops so hire
him I get zero dollars out of that but
he's just a fantastic person and your
company will be in better shape if you
hire him to do this what it is TL a + TI
+ is another modeling language like
alloy it does some things better than
alloy it does some things not as well as
alloy but there's an incredible amount
of resources out there on t li + we had
a pre conference yesterday that was all
TL a plus and if qi+ interests you a
really quick way to get into it is the
website learned TL a comm which also
happens to be a Hallel Wayne joint so
check that out and there's multiple
formal methods people here as strangers
lupus
finest in the slack Channel find me I
can point out friendly faces and that's
it thank you very much
[Applause]